a double epidemic is coming as covert
cases rise
an influenza wave is heading to the
northern hemisphere
what if you get both at the same time
the coronavirus is already new territory
its combination with influenza equally
unknown
winter will be a challenge the big
problem we're facing is that covid
can look a lot like flu and that's going
to create a lot of problems for our
hospitals
and so one of the most important things
we can do is to prevent flu
in our community and one of the most
important tools we have is the flu
vaccine
whether it impacts the behavior of the
coronavirus is another thing
but a flu vaccination could narrow the
diagnostic options when flu-like
symptoms occur
[Music]
doctors say it's more important than
ever to get your flu shot this year
facebook has launched a vaccine
information campaign it's also
banning ads that discourage people from
getting the jab
as dw reporter leonie von havenstein
found out
demand is surging experts say this could
be a test run for an eventual
coronavirus vaccine
little pinprick that protects against
the flu and
helps make sure the health system won't
be overwhelmed
doctors are worried about a widespread
flu outbreak alongside a new wave of
covid19
the demand for flu vaccinations is
higher this year than usual
people are a bit alarmed and scared and
that means that they are much more
willing to get vaccinated
a flu jab is usually recommended for
those over 60
pregnant women people with pre-existing
conditions and medical workers
but this year the vaccination is
available to everyone who wants one
german health minister yen span says
anyone who wants to have themselves and
their children vaccinated
should and can do so but if everyone in
germany decides to get a flu jab there
won't be enough of the vaccine to go
around
if we just vaccinate anyone who wants it
then it's quite possible that the people
who really need it may not be able to
get a vaccine at all in the end
that would be ethically and medically
wrong
to avoid that outcome the vaccination
commission recommends that high-risk
patients be vaccinated first
then the rest of the population germany
has never used up all its available
vaccines
nevertheless this year the flu
vaccination will serve as a test run for
an eventual corona vaccination
we can learn how a covit 19 vaccination
program might work from how influenza
vaccinations go this year
we'll probably vaccinate the same risk
groups first we'll have
much less of the vaccine at first
compared to the influenza vaccine
so we'll probably have to vaccinate
gradually starting with those who need
it most
in this respect you can see the flu
vaccine as a kind of test for the
population
the state and the medical profession are
hoping to learn valuable lessons from
this year's flu season
and how to prioritize future
vaccinations
nicola petrocero joins us from italy's
national institute for infectious
diseases in rome
nicola i got my flu shot last week was
that a good idea
that was a very very good idea i did
the same just 10 days ago
and i was also vaccinated against the
pneumococcal infection this is a very
very good idea because we have to
decrease
the the number of flu cases
firstly because flu it's a
a infection that should be prevented for
its complications secondary
because we have to avoid the pressure
during the
the winter season in the hospital for uh
cases to be admitted but tell me this
there are studies that show that it
could actually protect me against the
coronavirus
is is that can you substantiate that
there is no evidence that
the vaccination against flu can protect
against sars chronovirus too there are
different
viruses and they belong to different
families
uh the there is no interaction between
the two virus and the vaccination
against flu does not protect against the
coronavirus the the scope
to to be vaccinated is to
avoid another important disease in the
respiratory system that can can
worsen the course of a co-infection with
covet or to decrease
the pressure in the hospital of
admission and intensive care mechanical
ventilation cases
but what if i do get the flu and corona
at the same time
we don't have a vaccine against the
coronavirus
available so far so for your question uh
i have no a current reply i just
could say that if we add all the
vaccine at the same time they could be
done
together maybe next year when in
the both the vaccine vaccine will be
available they
could be done together new zealand has
seen a 99.8
reduction in flu cases following its
covert 19 response
is that because so many people are so
much more vigilant about washing hands
wearing masks
this is a possible explanation the most
likely explanation that
the measures to reduce the spread of
coronavirus can reduce also the spread
of flu this is correct and in my opinion
if we uh use properly masks wash
our hands and and we have a
physical distancing we can avoid both
flu
and carved and the the fact
that in new zealand the number of cases
of flu is
so dramatically decreasing can my
opinion
be due to the to the up to the utterance
of the people to
mitigating measures so for coving what's
your research reveal on
geographical differences on the spread
and severity of the flu and covert
the both flew and caved
are transmitted in the same way that is
the respiratory
respiratory way through droplets and the
contact
however um kavi the
patient can transmit infection
to uh to one covet patient to 2.5
persons on average whereas
transmissibility for
flu is lower than is around 1
1.5 and the case fatality rate
is around five percent up to
15 20 percent in uh people older than
80 years old for coffee whereas
for flu uh the more case fatality rate
that mortality is lower than uh than one
percent
and uh this is the big difference
between
the the two diseases in terms of
epidemiology
thank you very much for joining us today
a brief look at some other coronavirus
stories making news
another setback for hopes of a vaccine
anytime soon
johnson johnson's clinical trial of its
covert 19 vaccine
is on hold after a volunteer came down
with an unexplained illness
eli lilly has also paused a clinical
trial of an
antibody treatment
two taiwanese companies have designed a
covert rapid test using electronic chips
a coating on the biosensor attracts and
binds with the rna of the virus
in the flow of electrons through the
semiconductor changes
showing a negative or positive result in
a few minutes
and researchers in japan have used a
supercomputer to show how humidity
affects the dispersion of coronavirus
particles
the findings suggest contagion risks are
higher
in dry indoor conditions in winter they
say humidifiers could help limit
infections
when window ventilation is not possible
over to our science correspondent now
derek williams for another bookshelf
installment of his q a viewer segments
how do you make a vaccine for something
that mutates
i get asked this a lot um to answer
we have to look at the process of
evolution now just
like with living organisms the genetic
code
that governs how a virus is made changes
from generation to generation sometimes
in
small ways sometimes in big ones
the progeny if they survive eventually
will become
separate strains that are distinct from
their common ancestor
their genetic code has changed and and
that can change
how they look their structure and and
also
how they interact with potential hosts
for example
whether they can cause more or less
severe illness
what's key to creating a vaccine is the
speed
at which these changes occur in viruses
like the ones that cause influenza for
example which have
genomes that are less stable the rate of
change
is so rapid and random that we need a
new vaccine
to fight them every year we have to play
catch-up with flu
bugs all the time unfortunately
due to the way that sars cove 2 makes
copies of itself
its genome remains relatively stable
as far as we can tell a worldwide there
isn't a lot of genetic variation yet
among all the novel coronaviruses
circulating
in different parts of the planet and
because those groups
are so homogeneous theoretically a
vaccine that can prevent one
should be able to prevent them all um
what's interesting
and kind of scary is that is that when
we start to prevent
infections with a vaccine we'll also
start forcing saris cove to to change
in ways that will allow it to get around
the vaccine
but but that's a different question
[Music]
finally the pandemic has been a letdown
for live music lovers
many concert halls remain closed to
prevent the spread of the virus
[Music]
so members of the new york philharmonic
have decided to take their music to the
public
they are now staging performances on the
city's streets and in parks
the setting is a far cry from the
philharmonic's usual venue
but it gives the musicians a sense of
purpose and is likely to attract new
[Applause]
fans
you